نظرًا لأن السكان يحاولون بلا جدوى
إطفاء كرة النار التي سببتها
غارة جوية بصاروخ جهنم
أولاً ، اعتقدت أن هذا هجوم على
أفغانستان بأكملها لم أكن أعرف أن
الهجوم كان على منزلنا فقط ، وكان
الهدف سيارة سيدان بيضاء كانت
تحت جيشنا  المراقبة على
مدار الثماني ساعات الماضية وفقًا
لمسؤول أمريكي على علم بالعملية
التي قادها للتو إلى المجمع السكني
مع والد لسبعة
أطفال وعامل في المنظمات غير الحكومية زاماراي أمادي خلف عجلة القيادة ،
رأيت والدي مستلقيًا في السيارة
وكانت هناك شظايا في صدره
كان الدم يسيل في أذنيه في كل مكان ،
لكن الضربة لم تقتل
الأب البالغ من العمر 43 عامًا فحسب ، وفقًا
للعائلة ، كما قُتل رجلان آخران
مع سبعة أطفال ، كان ثلاثة
منهم أطفالًا صغارًا
كان أطفالنا في مثل هذه الحالة التي
كنا فيها.  حاول التعرف عليهم من
أيديهم وأذنيهم أو أنفهم إلى ابن عم زمرة ،
ولم تكن أيديهم وأرجلهم
سليمة وفي مكان واحد كانوا جميعًا
مقطوعين.
أجزاء متفحمة من الجمجمة مع
قطع من الشعر وقدم ذاب في
صندل كانت من بين البقايا التي تم نقلها إلى
ابن أخ زاماراي البالغ من العمر عامين وهو يرقد على نقالة بينما يضرب
أحد أقاربه برفق على
وجهه
[موسيقى]
عشرة توابيت مليئة  بقيت
أسمائهم مكتوبة باللون الأسود بشكل جزئي ، وهي
السمة الوحيدة المميزة
التي كانت لدينا معلومات استخباراتية جيدة جدًا ، ونزعم
أن لدينا معلومات استخبارية عن وجود
مادة متفجرة داخل السيارة كان من المقرر
استخدامها في هجوم وشيك على
مطار حمد كرزاي الدولي من قبل داعش
قبل أيام فقط.  قام مفجر انتحاري من تنظيم داعش
بتفجير نفسه عند بوابات آبي ،
ثلاثة عشر
جنديًا أمريكيًا وقتل أكثر من 170 أفغانيًا ،
لكن على مدار الأسبوعين الماضيين ، كانت سي إن إن
تحقق في مزاعم الجيش الأمريكي
بشأن غارة الطائرات بدون طيار ،
وأجرت مقابلات مع أكثر من عشرين شخصًا من
أفراد الأسرة الجيران.  موظفو المنظمات غير الحكومية
والعديد من خبراء القنابل الذين يرسمون
نسخة مختلفة جدًا من الأحداث ،
كما حصلنا على إمكانية الوصول إلى كاميرات الدوائر التلفزيونية
المغلقة  د بالسيارة من مكتب المنظمات غير الحكومية في ذلك
اليوم واستعرض جميع اللقطات
لمدة 15 عامًا ، عمل زامراي
كمهندس تقني للتثقيف الغذائي
الدولي ،
وهي منظمة غير حكومية مقرها الولايات المتحدة قدمت فول الصويا
إلى أفغانستان في عام 2003
للمساعدة في إطعام الفقراء والحد من
سوء التغذية.
بالنسبة للأشخاص
المحتاجين ومن ثم فهو
قلب رحيم ،
يقول مؤسس المنظمة إن تويوتا كورولا
زاماراي كانت تقودها تابعة للمنظمات غير الحكومية
وكان مسؤولاً عن جمع
الزملاء الذين يوزعون فول الصويا على
الأفغان في مخيمات اللاجئين وإدارة
العمليات التي
أخبرنا بها المسؤولون العسكريون  cnn
كانوا يراقبون الأحاديث من
منزل آمن لتنظيم الدولة الإسلامية في كابول لمدة 36 ساعة
عندما انسحبت سيارة من المجمع
حوالي الساعة 9 صباحًا يوم الأحد ،
فمن تلك اللحظة
بدأت طائرات المراقبة الأمريكية في تتبع السيارة
دون معرفة من كان السائق ولكن في
مقابلة مع أحد
زملاء الساموراي الذي كان معه طوال اليوم
ادعى أن الساموراي اصطحبه في
حوالي  الساعة 8:45 صباحًا
وحوالي الساعة 9 صباحًا توقفوا عند
منزل المدير القطري
لأخذ جهاز كمبيوتر محمول ليصطحبه إلى العمل لأنه
نسي حقيبة الكمبيوتر المحمول الخاصة به
هنا وأخذنا الكمبيوتر المحمول الخاص به مرة أخرى وقد
أخبرنا CNN أنه كانت هناك معلومات تفيد بأن
السيارة كانت موجهة من  المنزل الآمن
على طريق حول المدينة
يأمر السائق بمقابلة سائق
دراجة نارية وأنه فعل ذلك
قال زميل زاماراي بعد
جمع الكمبيوتر المحمول ، أخذوا
زميلًا آخر ثم توقفوا في
مقهى مزدحم لتناول الإفطار مدعيا أنهم
لم يتعاملوا مع  أي
راكبي دراجات نارية في رحلتهم إلى
المكتب ،
كان راكب الدراجة النارية الوحيد الذي تحدثوا إليه
هو حارس الأمن في مكتب المنظمات غير الحكومية الذي
شوهد هنا مع دراجته على الدوائر التلفزيونية المغلقة
خلال الساعات القليلة القادمة ، يقوم زامراي
وزملاؤه بمهام مختلفة
بزيارة مراكز أمن طالبان للحصول على
إذن بذلك  يستأنفون العمليات
منذ استحواذ طالبان ، كما يزورون أحد
البنوك ويعودون إلى العمل لتناول طعام الغداء في الساعة 2
مساءً في
حوالي الساعة 2:30 مساءً يبدأ الساموراي في ملء
وا  حاويات أخرى لأخذها إلى المنزل
لعائلته التي ليس لديها إمكانية الوصول إلى المياه الجارية ،
وهي مهمة كان يقوم بها منذ شهور
وفقًا لزملائه
يقولون إنهم بعد ذلك ساعدوا في تحميل
الحاويات في السيارة
قبل أن يغادروا حوالي الساعة 4 مساءً.
في نفس
الوقت ، أظهرت لقطات طائرة بدون طيار السائق وهو
يحمل طرودًا ثقيلة مع رجال آخرين
في السيارة
التي اشتبهوا في أنها متفجرات من
المحتمل أن تكون للهجوم الوشيك ،
يقول زملاء زاموراي إن زاموراي أوصلهم
قبل أن يقود سيارته إلى مجمع عائلته
أيضًا لمنزل إخوته الثلاثة
وعائلاتهم
حوله.  4 45 مساءً تقول الولايات المتحدة إن السيارة
وصلت إلى موقع سكني
واقترب رجل آخر من
السيارة ، وادعى الجيش أن لديه يقينًا معقولاً من
أن لديهم
هدفًا شرعيًا لتنظيم داعش وأخذوا اللقطة ،
وبعد ذلك فقط أدركنا أن
هناك ثلاثة  أطفال
بالقرب من
السيارة تقول العائلة إنه كان هناك بالفعل
سبعة أطفال
أخبرهم مسؤول أمريكي CNN أنه كان هناك
ثانوي مهم  من المحتمل أن يكون الانفجار
ناجمًا عن سترة ناسفة أو متفجرات
في السيارة والتي ربما قتلت
الأطفال.خبيرا متفجرات تحدثنا
إليهما وشاهد كلاهما نفس اللقطات التي تم تصويرها من
مكان الحادث.
أضرارًا هيكلية كبيرة للمباني المحيطة
والنباتات وأن السيارة
الرياضية متعددة الاستخدامات القريبة كانت ستقلب أحدها ،
ولاحظ أنه إذا شوهد انفجار ثانوي
من خلال المراقبة ، فمن المرجح
أن خزان غاز السيارة
ينفجر في الأفق مع وجود معلومات غير كاملة
ولكن إجراء  الضربة الجوية على
أي حال
هذه هي طريقة العمل
للجيش الأمريكي الآن وهناك الكثير من
المخاطر والأضرار التي تلحق بالمدنيين والتي تأتي
مع تحقيق عسكري
أمريكي في غارة الطائرات بدون طيار حيث أن
واحدًا على الأقل من هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
قُتلوا كان من داعش  الميسر هل
قتل آخرون نعم
هناك آخرون قتلوا من هم لا
نعرف ولكن في هذه المرحلة ث  أعتقد أن
الإجراءات قد تم اتباعها بشكل صحيح ، وأنا
أعلم أنها ضربة صالحة
، حيث دافع بيان البنتاغون الصادر في
نهاية الأسبوع عن الضربة بناءً على
معلومات استخبارية جيدة
تمنع تهديدًا وشيكًا وأنه
لا يوجد جيش آخر يعمل بجد أكثر مما
نفعل لمنع وقوع إصابات في صفوف المدنيين
ولكن هناك أسئلة كثيرة مطروحة  تربوا
على ما إذا كانوا قد حصلوا على الهدف الخطأ
كيف تعرف من السماء ما
يقول هنا يا
أخي كان هناك أطفال في
السيارة وحولها وقمت باستهدافهم ،
أليس هذا جريمة لقد أتيت إلى هنا
وحطمت قلوبنا إلى
أشلاء  في اليوم التالي ، شنت داعش
هجومًا صاروخيًا على المطار من سيارة
تويوتا كورولا ، حيث تم إحصاء الهجوم بواسطة
نظام الدفاع الصاروخي في
نفس اليوم الذي دفنت فيه عائلة زامراي
قبورهم العشرة القتلى على أحد التلال المهجورة
المطلة على كابول التي
تنتمي إلى عائلة تطالب بالإجابات
والعدالة آنا كوريين  CNN هونغ كونغ
لك